to house Gomez - Pierre - and welcome to
prop hunt oh the sign of disappointment
I think this is it jumbo yeah hell yeah
did it give away that we were just the
only two standing bottles in the whole
room it was kind of a giveaway not gonna
Tom what are you going
okay I'm sticking with you where are you
going come in okay yeah okay
this is right way oh really yeah oh so
he should be close by tango younger come
oh my god oh my god God moon jump gochop
gochop you can drink you can press E to
quit share to another item press Q to
switch item not that not the same I let
it go with you let it go me no you what
are you doing
Oh finally I know so hard - terrible you
guys should be ashamed of yourself
Oh oh my god I wet myself dude it's all
it's just a matter of trial and error
screen jail just gonna watch your movie
I'm the way yeah that's the problem what
is that oh nothing nothing I'm stuck
I got me [ __ ] boots commit you have 12
seconds well sure counting yeah how do
you know I'm sorry I started felt nice I
got mixed by randomly shooting yeah I
fight under the thing so you saw my
barrel moving huh I saw you I saw an
arrow jump over my head there's not a
barrel yeah
this randomly turned around and like to
drag yes I just said what hey what what
I could see you're shooting the object
today don't look over at me you stay
looking at the floor shut up
that's were looking at it shut shut up
got my head not a player
hang on is normally something in this
pipe but there isn't now oh no it's a
[ __ ] tape cat following me I don't
know you were there I didn't see you
where did you come from I was behind
like this crazy hair ken was there along
and I finally made my escape
ready go I'm in found it found them both
thought about
split away wait does he get away
hey yes can get apply Bernie no just
[ __ ] head height she's hiding Mary if
I knew what I was did I'd be more secure
that's what it is
oh you Jojo you Joe Lobeck swagger oh
you did not just do that huh huh huh huh
I don't know if I can fit through things
that's the problem I said I think I won
t come with you is it ever
someone just wise okay go Tom go tom
gosh honey orange calm down Oh No the
are you [ __ ] now
I don't know what is was a bottle a
little catchy a ball yeah
God Tom yeah I'll try you want to have
two minutes I can do this
hi there hey no no no I am actually a
bottle when I press if you enjoyed this
episode of prop hunt we're having a ton
of fun playing at some guy D Bros one
more maybe like if you do hit subscribe
to become a birthday I'll see in the
next one
stay awesome bros Belgian come here you
[ __ ] mouth come don't you run away
from me